Karine Jean-Pierre have finally
addressed the horrific wildfires in
Hawaii she just gets some details wrong
senator harino who I said the president
spoke to just last night he thanked the
president for the immediate support of
federal agencies have delivered for
residents of Hawaii Senator harino if
you've never heard of her or him I guess
Karine chumpier actually actually
misgenders the the senator how the
turntables Senator harino is a woman and
her name's not harino it's hirono and
she's not even just a minor back bench
Senator she's a senator who's on TV all
the time she never stops flapping her
gums White House spokesman might be
forgiven for getting the name wrong if
it's a member of the opposition party
Senator Maisie hirono is one of the most
outspoken members of the president's own
party